la unidad es una alianza ampliada con
Finlandia y que estamos listos para
acoger a Suecia Espero que Turquía
ratifique su adhesión Próximamente como
lo dijo el presidente erdogan
esta decisión de dos miembros de la
Unión Europea es la prueba evidente de
la derrota estratégica
a la cual las presiones del presidente
Putin están llevando a Rusia la
seguridad colectiva de los aliados
se fortalece Y tenemos nuevos recursos
de cooperación y de acción después de la
unidad es la determinación la que ha
estado presente en nuestros debates y
decisiones esta determinación es la de
los aliados para asegurar su seguridad
colectiva el artículo cinco produce
todos sus efectos
respetar Rusia y
exige el respeto a Rusia en todos los
niveles
este artículo permite la acción de las
Naciones y de la Unión Europea que está
Armando eficazmente a Ucrania desde hace
un año y medio durante esta Cumbre hemos
reafirmado la postura de lo que se
decidió en Madrid y también adoptamos
nuestro plan de defensa avanzamos hacia
la reforma de la arquitectura de comando
y hemos validado nuevas iniciativas como
la de los estados bálticos sobre la
defensa aérea a la cual Francia
contribuirá y que se inscribe de manera
lógica con la Cumbre que tuvimos Hace
algunos días en París con algunos
ministros de defensa europeos
Francia presente en este conflicto desde
el comienzo contribuye a la defensa de
nuestro flanco Oriental
con soldados en Rumanía en lestonia y
con una participación de la policía
aérea con algunas operaciones en
lituania que se reanudarán Próximamente
También estamos determinados seguimos
determinados a apoyar a Ucrania aquí
estamos la otan no juega un papel como
tal en la en el hecho de armar a Ucrania
pero su apoyo es decisivo y es crucial
que los aliados cada uno de ellos sigan
haciendo lo máximo Para apoyar a Ucrania
de manera concreta es exactamente lo que
estamos haciendo Y con nuestro apoyo
Ucrania ha hecho retroceder a las
fuerzas rusas en varias ocasiones en
kiev en carro y así continúa Estados
Unidos han desempeñado un papel muy
importante y les agradezco por esto y la
Unión Europea y sus miembros también
están cargando con lo que les
corresponde y con el compromiso que les
corresponde la ayuda militar a Ucrania
es importante y el apoyo presupuestal
esta crisis como lo vemos todos los días
es un momento Aliado de los aliados y un
momento europeo a la vez nunca la otan
había gastado tanto para su defensa
ni sus reglas se habían visto tan
presionadas pero tenemos que hacerlo
dentro del marco de la contraofensiva
lanzada por Ucrania Francia ha
construido bastante ya sea con cañones
con blindados con misiles también
lo mismo que Italia también con los
aliados decidió enviar tanques
a Ucrania y he decidido ir más lejos y
enviarles misiles de largo alcance que
les dará más capacidad y una
mayor fuerza en la fase que viene
para que su defensa en territorio
ucraniano
sea más importante pero lo que queremos
es que el tiempo
actúe en favor de Ucrania primero porque
Rusia ya ha mostrado sus primeros signos
de división
una decisión tomada por varios
Mercenarios
cuya facción es bien conocida que
cometen lo peor desde el cáuca hasta el
continente africano esto nos ha mostrado
La debilidad del poder ruso en estas
últimas semanas pero sobre todo los
esfuerzos que llevamos haciendo este
tiempo nos ofrecen un signo de la
serenidad de nuestro apoyo Ucrania y
este es un punto muy importante Rusia es
frágil políticamente militar
militarmente más de lo que se creía y
nuestro apoyo es duradero nuestro apoyo
Ucrania es duradero además de los
esfuerzos que hemos hecho a corto plazo
Seguiremos dando todos los medios
durante el verano durante el invierno
mientras sea necesario continuaremos
nuestro apoyo Ese es el sentido de los
compromisos de seguridad que los
miembros del g7 han tomado frente a
Ucrania todos los aliados pueden unirse
a este apoyo algunos lo hicieron durante
la sesión de esta tarde
han decidido unirse a este compromiso y
esto marca un esfuerzo un esfuerzo
colectivo a largo plazo para el apoyo a
Ucrania
además de la unidad y la determinación
la eficacia ha estado presente en
nuestros trabajos la coherencia política
y el compartir de la responsabilidad
militar
el desempeño colectivo de la alianza
ha sido importante fue difícil adaptarse
a las situaciones ahora pero la agresión
de Rusia
contribuyó a su refuerzo
en cada uno de estos temas Francia fue
coherente y ha dado ejemplo con una ley
de programación militar
cuyas cuyos trabajos estratégicos
empezaron en 2017 y desde 2019 en
aumentado fuertemente en nuestro
presupuesto y también la ley que acaba
de ser votada por el parlamento que nos
permitirá en 2024-2030
aumentar nuestros esfuerzos así el
presupuesto de nuestros ejércitos se
duplicará no esperamos el comienzo de la
guerra pero sí estamos
contribuyendo a este esfuerzo quiero que
los aliados
y la Unión Europea y sus miembros están
asumiendo una mayor responsabilidad por
la seguridad del continente de manera
muy coherente con los compromisos En el
seno de la alianza y como ustedes saben
cuando Francia ha empujado por una mayor
autonomía estratégica de Europa y para
reforzar una Europa de la defensa hemos
defendido la complementariedad de este
esfuerzo con el enfoque de la otan Yo
pienso que este es un debate que ya
hemos desarrollado y colectivamente
hemos confirmado la complementaria de
estos dos enfoques así compartimos la
carga y también
apoyamos
de lado y lado nuestra seguridad ambos
debían ser conjugados Y esto es
coherente con la agenda de Versalles que
definimos cuánto Francia ocupaba la
presidencia del Consejo europeo en marzo
del 2022
hemos visto que amenazas
multiformes que
más allá del tema militar hay riesgos
cibernéticos y ahí en esto hay actores
estatales y no estatales en este
contexto los aliados deben poder contar
con socios confiables que compartan su
compromiso por la paz y la seguridad y
que
consoliden No solamente la Unión Europea
sino también Australia Japón Nueva
Zelanda y Corea
Fueron por ello invitados a esta cumbre
en estos días
me entrevisté con varios de estos
dirigentes y les dije al consejo de la
otan que también debemos estar atentos a
la seguridad de los países más
vulnerables y actuar porque las
múltiples crisis sanitarias de seguridad
económica y social que han vivido estos
últimos años no se conviertan en nuevas
crisis globales a este respecto y más
allá de los mensajes de apoyo y más allá
de las decisiones muy claras que hemos
tomado tanto respecto a Ucrania como
respecto a nuestra propia seguridad como
ya lo dije en nuestros debates siempre
mencionamos tanto esta mañana como esta
tarde siempre mencionamos la necesidad
de empezar con Los Grandes actores de
los países en desarrollo de todos los
continentes trabajar con para mostrar
que defendemos la carta de las Naciones
Unidas y nuestra estabilidad
internacional y también para mostrar que
nunca tenemos la voluntad de instalar un
doble estándar sino más bien una
determinación para resolver las grandes
crisis internacionales creo que Francia
lo demostró cuando cuando acogió hace
unas semanas este Cumbre por el nuevo
pacto financiero internacional cuya
vocación era la de entrevistarse con
estos países y establecer nuevas reglas
financieras para resolver los asuntos
del clima y de la lucha contra la
pobreza en el contexto que acabo de
describir esto es importante
geopolíticamente para evitar una
división del mundo que de alguna manera
nos volvería a nuestros conflictos de
vecindad y mostraría que esto no es
asunto de todos pero aquí creo que
tenemos una agenda coherente que muestra
que Francia está intentando resolver
estos problemas de manera global